Esta es una función en JavaScript que
genera el enésimo número de Fibonacci
usando tanto la recursividad como la memorización.
Así que vamos a revisarlo y ver en realidad lo
que hace la computadora paso a paso. Así que lo
primero que hace es declarar esta estructura de
datos que es un objeto vacío de JavaScript llamado
memo, y ahí es donde veremos la memorización más
tarde. Luego define la función fib y finalmente
invoca la función fib con un valor de entrada
igual a 5. Entonces, lo primero que sucede es
que entramos a la función fib con n igual a
5. Esta primera condición es falsa porque n no es
igual a 0 y no es igual a 1. La segunda condición
es falsa porque 5 no está en la estructura
de datos memo, que está completamente vacía,
y entraremos en esta tercera condición. Bueno,
en realidad no es una condición, ¿cierto?,
así que entramos en este bloque else y quiere
calcular cuánto es Fibonacci de 5 invocando a la
función fib de n menos 1 más lo que nos regrese la
función fib de n menos 2, de modo que lo primero
que hace es invocar fib de n menos 1. Así que
eso va a ser fib de 4 e inmediatamente invoca
la función y ahora estamos en la función fib con
n igual a 4. Esto es falso, esto es falso, así que
estamos aquí de nuevo y esta vez quiere calcular
resultado sumando fib de 3 más fib de 2. Entonces
primero invoca a fib de 3 y estamos en fib para n
igual a 3. Esto es falso, esto es falso, y ahora
vamos a calcular fib de 3 como fib de 2 más fib
de 1. Inmediatamente invoca fib de 2, así que
estamos en fib para n igual a dos. Esto es falso
esto, es falso, y va a calcular fib de 2 como fib
de 1 más fib de 0. Así que inmediatamente llama
a fib de 1 y ahora, finalmente, esto es cierto.
Entonces regresará n que es uno de nuevo
y terminará volviendo a la función fib
cuando n era igual a 2 porque ahora tiene
el resultado de la primera invocación a fib.
Ahora necesita invocar a fib de 0 y obtener el
valor de resultado, así que estamos en fin para
n igual a 0. Ahora esa primera condición
es cierta de nuevo por lo que devolverá n,
que es igual a 0, y regresará a cuando n era igual
a 2, y ahora tiene el valor de resultado. Así que
ahora puede actualizar el objeto memo con el
valor de resultado para n igual a 2 y podemos
ver efectivamente que el objeto se actualiza por
allí. Luego devuelve el resultado para fib de 2.
Muy bien, así que ahora estamos de vuelta
en fib de 3 y en fib de 3 hemos invocado a
fib de 2 y ahora quiere llamar a fib de 1. Así
que estamos de vuelta cuando n es igual a 1,
una vez más devuelve 1, y ahora sabe
cuánto es el resultado de fib de 3,
y el valor de resultado es igual a 2.
Puede actualizar la estructura memo
con el valor del resultado y regresarlo.
Así que ahora estamos de vuelta cuando n
es igual a 4 y ya calculó fib de 3. Entonces
ahora necesita invocar a fib de 2, y esta vez,
cuando invoca a fib de 2, n es igual a
2. Encuentra que en esta, efectivamente,
en la estructura de datos memo para que pueda
regresar el valor de la estructura cuando n es
igual a 2 por lo que va a obtener el resultado
de 1 y no tiene que hacer el cálculo recursivo.
Así que ahora estamos de vuelta con n igual
a 4 y ahora sabemos que el fib de 4 es igual
a 3. Podemos actualizar el memo y regresar.
Ahora finalmente volvemos a cuando n es igual
a 5 en la función fib, invoca a fib de 4
y luego sólo necesita invocar a fib de 3.
Entonces vemos que es falso, pero aquí 3 está
en la estructura memo, para que pueda devolver
el valor en la estructura memo que es igual a
2 y vuelve aquí. Ahora sabe que el fib de 5 es
igual a 5 y puede actualizar la estructura
memo con ese valor de resultado y regresar.
¡Uf!, y así se realizó toda la
función recursiva memorizada.